hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
we are dreaming the sweet delectable
dreams of the dreamless we are
experiencing a lovely time here and we
have got so much more to do so get your
lazy asses I think we need to go for
eventually we're gonna need advanced
research because I don't want to be
waiting on anything anytime soon oh yeah
and I can't pause I gotta remember that
I cannot pause pausing is bad and any
minute and I love you lazy there you go
hey you saw your friend that's so nice
oh we got poop poop air we've got a
problem with poop err gotta get out Eve
we got to get up and we gotta go we
gotta take care of that actually pretty
soon so can we get just this I just need
an and this because I need it to fall
somewhere I know they'll get it
eventually but I need them to do it
sooner rather than later because we if
we let the bad oxygen pile up that could
have negative repercussions I like the
music that's nice that's real nice I
like that
oh yeah pippick those are incubating
already okay do we have any more that we
can put in here we got more meal wood we
need to get food going or else we are
going to die which is in case you didn't
know not good salt water cool I knew
that this biome had oceans in it but oh
so that's good because that means whoa
look at all the growth there's still a
lot of differences in this game that I'm
not 100% sure about because well it's
just different but eventually I'm gonna
get into the new stuff and I actually
want to make a base that is something I
could be proud of
we're just gonna put polluted water in
the area I put that as six because that
is just one of those things that needs
to be done before everything else I want
to get better about the priority system
because that is something I actually
have not been very good about so I am
gonna eventually do that and eventually
I will have things in relatively good
order oxygen is okay this isn't the best
place to have the oxygen and it's not
flowing out that way because that's
completely blocked off hey can you uh
now they're doing it there good good job
you could chew you really do me proud
and me ma proud of you very proud of ya
you wash your hands probably just on the
way out though
hey good yeah good job researching okay
so I'm gonna go ahead and get advanced
research going because I am God here and
I whatever I say goes so anyone that
backs asses me is gonna get a face full
of my hand and I'm gonna slap you across
the room and you will never sass me
again so don't even try it
sorry I had to yell at you like that I
apologize for nothing did I get
water-cooler hey you know what hey come
on let's do this I know that's not the
right place for it but hey come on let's
let's do this it's gonna be a cruise six
close my eyes and I open them again
there won't be poop water running down
my bass we've got a yellow we got a
yellow alert everybody we got a yellow
alert yep yellow alert we've got a
yellow alert on the mopping we've got a
yellow alert
pick up the pee water in the poop water
we've got a yellow alert I think they
made this specifically for this scenario
oh now everyone's gonna be soaked oh
there's more okay all right oh you know
boy all right you know what I'm gonna
cancel the yellow alert and we're just
gonna get to that when we get to that
actually they got to get to it soon so
frankly all right fine yellow alert
Oh everyone's probably disgusting Oh
gotta bet it's a yellow I guess we don't
need a yellow alert I guess we could
just make it like a higher priority by a
little bit okay you know what I'm gonna
gonna make it a nice oh wait no you need
to dig that out and you need to put this
there yeah it's fine Oh God all right
we're fine all right why are you waking
up again light oh this new you
woke up you could you know you could use
all tired unroasted stress going up
immunity going down okay whatever it's
fine that sucks but we'll get over it
that's a lot of water here I think I
need to make a ridge yeah we're gonna do
it like that instead of that okay all
right good hey we're done hey we got it
okay what how did you get over there how
did you are you gonna die are you oh
[Laughter]
you're going to dial that Pinkle touch
knows what dinkelpuss is doing okay okay
all right not the worst thing in the
world but pretty bad I gotta say pretty
bad not horrible but relatively unger
dokay before they do this and cause an
ecological collapse from all of the
water that's gonna come spilling out how
about we just finished the outside here
first
that way they definitely actually build
it correctly okay at least that's going
through okay
crisis has been moderately averted it is
not completely averted but it is
somewhat averted so if I can keep the
aversion going then we're gonna be okay
oh you I can't get rid of both of
those or else they're not gonna make it
all right fine then oh you're not gonna
be able to you're not thinking this one
through buddy how about you get how
about you move over here
then you break that debt there you go
you smart you use big brain oh yeah
there you go buddy there you go see
how's it feel to be smart yeah but it
feels good doesn't it feels real good
smartest aware smart as well you so whip
smart you whip crack smart you smart
like this smart as well okay so now that
I've somehow avoided killing everybody I
need to get some frickin food going the
only way that I'm gonna be able to do
that is by building this and eventually
I'm gonna get light in here because
that's the only way that I'm gonna be
able to make these block meal wood oh
where did those come from hey that's
good okay Neil woods going up and we
just finished researching something I
think we've finished researching
advanced research which is great very
good but I'm gonna do sanitation next
because I want to get these sons of
these dirty disgusting pieces of
garbage I want to get them some goddamn
she I did I was researching decor why
didn't I finish the core that's what I
was hoping for a core oh you pooping I
don't know did you guys not wash your
goddamn hands because there wasn't two
of them how you suck oh you suck you
disgusting creatures and why isn't it
pointing to the right oh it's bad time
well better just go to bed disgusting
hands alright um why didn't I make this
one more up I don't know because I'm an
idiot oh my god wait I can't pause oh
it's like perching like a bird
alright I I don't care who you are it
asked you oh you better get to the
bathroom better go
write a girl better get out of here come
on alright I think we need one more
turlet definitely need another turlet
okay we're gonna dig this out we're
gonna connect these we're gonna turn
these into rooms eventually water here
but we got plenty of water here so I'm
not too worried
about nothing you're not gathering by
outside recreation room I'll have a
recreation room how do you make a
recreation room oh all right well this
is gonna be the rec room
I guess stupid piece of garbage I hate
you I hate you all right we're gonna put
it right there that's real nice that's
perfect
great yeah oh that's real nice all right
I'm also gonna put because I'm a smart
smart that plans ahead boo incus I'm
gonna put that there because a bottle
emptier for the clean water is important
because I don't have a clean water spill
yet but with this precariously sitting
above my head I don't think that it will
rain down upon me someday I hope this
won't be turned into a flashback in a
later episode when it doth rain on my
head and I hope that death there ain't
no ocean above me that is also going to
rain upon mine skull because I would
sure be bye had a funny idea though
right ha ha ha
very humorous right have I finished
researching that oh you haven't even
started what are you doing research damn
it you all suck I hate you skill points
available who's got skills
tinkle tush Oh improve tinkering Oh
tinkles there's gonna be better Tinkler
that doesn't sound right but I can't
find out why it's wrong so tinkle push
you gonna be so good at tinkering you
gonna tinkle so good you tinkle all over
the place here there every it's done
sound right the more I say it the more
whoa all right you okay cool that's
weird
all right insufficient oxygen generation
how we doin for oxygen pretty good I
mean it's not that bad how we doing on
heat getting a little toasty in here I
think eventually I want to move those up
at least get these batteries out of here
move them more up once this research
done I will do the power research
because then I can get some bigger
batteries up here and I can just be like
those are just gonna be little B my like
natural heat sink so that yeah
now I'm gonna research better her better
power so that we can have that and as
long as we have that then I don't have
to think about stabbing myself in my
eyes Oh God I thought it was don't know
that startled me
colony summary what does that mean I did
not just get that what happened oh look
at this
wowie Zowie Wow why are you guys getting
hungry I don't like that Wow average
power wasted yeah I get that travel
times going up that's probably not good
mmm efficiencies going down stress is
getting up wild critters are fine mmm
interesting though rocket missions under
way well you know I'm not doing that
okay let's get a new friend oh great
I don't know who to get here I think
Jean Jean Jean
I'll call you I mean who over here but I
will call you he who he who sure loves
he who and why is this not a rec room
decora
out de coeur all right here comes a
flower flower pod in the corner and a
lamp we're gonna it's the saddest decor
I ever did see but there she is blink
all right I sure got him put that there
we're gonna put this there we're gonna
send send her up here and then we're
gonna would nope we're just planning for
the future
all right sleepy tom junction you lazy
pieces of garbage oh man I am just god
damn of me how white the get go to bed
beer do go to bed go to bed go to bed
don't stop turning her get to be your
butt to bed
[Laughter]
that's not fun he who ain't funny
I swear he who I swear he who ain't
funny
Oh bath time wow they they don't do
anything during bath time you know
actually I'm gonna switch swoosh these
so that bath time happens right before
work so that you know they take a bath
eventually I'm gonna get these because
those have got to be little food things
and whatever that is I'm gonna try to be
a little surgical now of where things
are this is probably a hatch or
something like that and everyone's so
nice here I don't get it doesn't make
any sense I thought these guys would be
just at each other's throats like 90% of
the time but apparently not well beam
Wow we did hey they're all celebrate we
did research we did it we got power guys
we got power
let's get these sons some shares
artistic expression automation oh god oh
god oh god
automation uh I gotta learn it
eventually I had a hydrocarbon combust
what what okay uh but that's not what
we're gonna worry about right now
there's a lot more stuff here than I
thought there were let's just focus on a
nice shower cuz like that's all I can
really think about sometimes just where
am I gonna get a shower that's that's
pretty much it
we'll start with three we'll expand as
necessary cuz I have a bad habit of
building way too much way more than I
would ever need and I don't know why but
you know here we are I've said it many
times I'm kind of an idiot yeah there's
a lot of poopy err uh when are we gonna
be able to get the do two I where do we
where do we get to be older Iser where's
the deodorizer there she is there she
blows decontamination okay uh don't
worry about that soon that's next up
that is next we're gonna worry about
that exactly next and then we're gonna
start specializing people because this
is gonna be what we have for a while
let me put some ceiling lights here da
da da da da da Boing cos and and goddamn
it I didn't make it even because I'm an
idiot myself
it's excess but at least it's even and I
care more about it being even than I
care about not wasting power it's
actually uproot this cuz we're gonna
make it a nice even split of Brier
blossom on one side and then mealworm on
the other and this just because again
I'm an and I care more about
aesthetics than actual functionality and
I don't know why cuz I'm not in my life
I am NOT an aesthetics type person I am
like a living trashcan that walks
through life just stinking up the entire
earth with my stupid and I I don't there
isn't a Febreze in the world that could
possibly conceal this I'm like a train
wreck that people can't look away from
but in life and as a human and I don't
even know if I'm actually human that's
questionable at best because the
baseline average human can probably do
far more than I could just in a general
self maintenance style thing anyway now
that my self-esteem has properly been
plummeted I will go uh set these guys
tasks on the next big thing that will
end up destroying me supercomputer yeah
let's do one of those when did I make
this not form it's not even I hate it
fine we'll just maybe these will be the
small rooms that's it that's the small
rooms okay while they take care of that
I'm going to the bathroom and oh
actually let me put the supercomputer is
gonna be in there and I'm gonna put
another research station right yeah
and then I'm gonna put a nice whatever
the skill scrubber is research fund
I mean it's something to put in the room
I I guess I'm not gonna probably use it
so I won't power it but you know at
least it'll be there okay while they're
working on that I'm gonna I'm gonna go
buy ro Oh explain myself to you
you haven't done anything you jerk wads
oh we're starving oh oh we got no food
this happen how could this happen we can
handle this
this is fine I can't pause I forgot that
was rule
I can't pause Oh God okay uh problem
solving this goes whatever's in there I
know there's something down here I set
him to task
too much on this this doesn't matter
let's just cancel that we'll worry about
that later
well we're not gonna worry about all
this okay cool sorry I didn't mean to
pause her please forgive me I got I got
my cinnamon roll but I can't eat it oh I
love cinnamon rolls probably cuz I am
one
anyway okay we got problem fixed I'm
okay so there's Muk root down here we
need those but how we're gonna get to
those there's all this carbon dioxide
they can't really hold their breath for
that long whoa okay right no oh God Oh
God I thought we're doomed so this
is the co2 trap right so watch this this
is real smart I'm big smart my big brain
here we go boink boink is blowing kiss
in blowing doink doink ascends blinky
doink and suddenly our co2 trap now has
a nice distribution of a death I love
okay so the idea here is that they will
basically if that can just float what
that can just float I've fought this
entire time that the only way that could
do something cuz if it was actually
touching it could just float okay
whatever my mind is currently exploded
but whatever okay it's fine so I have to
get you because whoa because I there's
nothing else I could get it's gonna die
cuz there's no there's no polluted you
can live over here tiny baby hungry oh
yeah well look your tiny baby there's
some over here but not you could be over
here you could be over here can I can I
wrangle you after you cannot wrangle oh
okay can't wrangle well you're gonna die
but then when you die we're gonna eat
you hey is that so bad you know what I'm
gonna we're gonna just follow you real
close and I'm gonna eat my cinnamon roll
and imagine I'm using your succulent
flesh
oh crap food shortage well better not
think about food yep
farty little thing sleep sweetly
dreamily
I'm dreaming about the flu for who I'm
dreamin about some tasty delicious
things starving in the future are you
gonna be sweet or you gonna be succulent
when we okay I need to do some more
research we're gonna do we're gonna do
pressure management just to get those so
we will have them I'm gonna leave you
for now but just for now I'll get to you
eventually eventually I'll get ya but
for now it's fine but now everything's
good anyway okay so I got good news and
I got bad news good news is we got the
co2 thing coming out here so we can
start pumping out oxygen down here so we
can start digging out all this or the
bad news is we're gonna die gonna die a
horrible death we're gonna die a
horrible death death is coming to us but
before we die I'm hoping that I'm gonna
be able to create some kind of a
semblance of excavation project that
allows to get everything that we need to
not die it's gonna be real tough what I
think that wheeze could do it but only
just barely okay makes sense good strip
this whole place top to bottom those are
doing pretty good we can now get rid of
these we got those that'll help shut the
heat up we could wait we could do
microbe mushing that is definitely a
thing that we could do there's nothing
stopping us from doing microbe bushing
microbe mushing is cool I like it all
the cool kids are mushing their microbes
so why can't I also mush my microbes
it's not ideal but it's at least better
than starving
and frankly I all take not starving um
we hungee
we honky we can do pilots now but I
can't
even now I'm gonna worry about plumbing
after I worry about getting everyone not
dead I know there's a food shyam aware
of the fact that there's a food shortage
I am fully cognizant of that a meal
preparation yeah let's go meal prep and
then college for all right to the
refrigeration food is oxygen is fine for
now food that's where we have a problem
why are you dead why are you eating down
here as because you're not putting food
in the thing put the food in the thing
everyone's travelling too much
everyone's moving too far and it's not
good everything needs to be localized
everything needs to be I needed people
minimize people's travel times get
people specialized into their own little
zone so that they don't go all over wish
you wash you the place there should be
like one or two people that are runners
that are sending everything wishy-washy
everywhere but me and this needs to be
not here ok microbe musher a mush bar
preferable to starvation what does it
take to make a mush bar dirt and water
Hey we got plenty of those you know make
some dirt and water lice loaf
we don't have lice so let's just let's
just make much bars I I don't like it or
frankly it is in fact better than
starving which is something that is
quite the possibility at this juncture
so we just worry about with so little
food we did let this get to this point I
have no idea once we get the research
done to be able to get to the next step
we could always do the grilled mush
barking which is what's scolding oh oh
oh my god oh my god get out of there
what are you why is it so hot what what
the igneous rock that's so hot Javad
this it's so hot get out of there oh my
god can either do not we can't we can't
get any of that because if we bring that
up to where we need to be that's gonna
bring heat upward let's forget all of
that oh my god just don't touch any
that Oh still complete this project oh
my god let's just see we got to seal
that off uh-oh somebody crisis okay we
got to just seal this off because I
can't have that be that way because if
we allow that to happen then it's like
we are going to be screwed because I
cannot have them building things with
hot material otherwise the buildings
that they make up here will be way
warmer than they need to be and that's
bad
um okay do I need to give people jobs I
don't think anybody here wants to cook
will receive a morale bonus for learning
it oh that's good okay you could chew is
now a better at digging beer news better
at operating me my's better at building
who who can't cook uh he who you're
gonna be art I guess you know sure yeah
whatever you're gonna be an artist Oh
yellow act it's just uh yellow alert
I got it we got we got we have to we
need food now and if I wait any longer
starving is gonna start and that's not
good maybe not a yellow maybe I could
just make it look like a six you're
hungry oh god he's hungry oh god we need
another one of those that's gonna be too
slow electric grill wait no we just need
to at this point we just need basic I
don't care if it's mush I don't care
what it is
we need food and right now or everyone
is going to die that is it that's
there's no other way other than that if
people don't start getting food right
immediately now they will die and that's
how dire the situation is at this moment
no power wise or no power Oh cuz we're
researching to but you know forget the
research it's turtle it is not research
right now cuz we don't need it we need
food we need food so badly you just date
that right away didn't you
you ate that right away yeah I know it's
bad I am aware it's bad we have no power
why don't we have power because no one's
on the generator we're gonna die we're
gonna die we're gonna die but we're
sleeping sleeping's great let's matches
if we kill the hatches we won't have to
worry
about anything anymore as the
temperature coming up through there it's
holding pretty okay this is still
getting this is getting kind of toasty
and I don't like that cuz it's gonna get
in the water and then it's gonna make
everything toasty and why this you have
to be a freakin volcano directly beneath
my base that's like the worst thing that
ever could have happened that is
legitimately the worst thing that could
have happened that is awful
I'll worry about it later we don't have
time to worry about it right now we just
got to get people getting power to us
and they're not why are they no no there
does not Oh God
Oh cuz it's more than one can make okay
I see so let's just make another general
tour well there's one microbe mush
we need more microbe mush I know they're
spending a lot of time walk over room
I'm where of this idea I am aware of
this and I don't like it look I don't
like it I wish it wasn't this way but
how else are we supposed to do oh you're
sick Oh food poisoning supposed to be
good at this game
we are doomed we are doomed oh how a
printing pod how Gaza give us dirt how
did they know we needed food delicious
sweet dirt
I love eating dirt it's my loves dirt
we all loved her little I got great
recipe passed down from my grandma me ma
little dirt put some water in it you
mush it up real good we're eating
disgusting what is become of us not like
this
a nice flower pot and a lamp everybody
loves lamb sick duplicants I don't know
how to fix that how do I fix that I
would hope that you would just get
better over time but I don't know that I
honestly have no idea if that's actually
going to happen so unfortunately I have
to pause here we are in the middle
crisis we've got so little food and I in
this temperature there's multiple crises
there's temperature I'm pausing because
I'm and in the episode there's multiple
crises we got temperature that's oh my
god it's just flooding it's gonna cool
me it is it's you there's a volcano
directly beneath me what do we do about
that nothing we can do anyway so but
right now we just got a food that we got
to worry about and then we'll worry
about the water the temperature
situation then we got to worry about
water because we're gonna be running out
of water cuz now we're using water to
cook food with and these aren't growing
fast enough but it's fine it is ok we
will make it through this because we are
strong and so long as we are strong we
will survive right right good great good
yes the answer is yes we will survive
maybe or not I am good at this game I
thought I was let me know what you
thought down the comments below hope
you're enjoying it and I swear I'm not
gonna let him die I will not let them
die so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]